- My wife Mrs. Unlimited said I have to be a lifestyle brand now.
Lockett up that cash, right?
- Totally, Russ.
God, he’s so lame but so good at football.
- So we're finding spots around Gridiron Heights that will...
Say it with me, 12s.
Let. Russ. Cook.
- We can't have fans yet.
- Oh.
Our first stop is in Atlanta,
home to the two-time Super Bowl-losing Falcons.
I’m here with Lemon Pepper Matt—
- No one calls me that.
So what I do is toss the wings to Julio for a bit
but then let Calvin Ridley finish them off.
For the cornbread—
- I like to make things cornier.
- No, but I—
- Then turn on the burners and scramble!
- WHY DID YOU LET HIM TURN ON THE GAS, DAN?
- I’M TRYING MY BEST.
- Thanks for letting me cook, Atlanta.
There’s nothing I like more than cooking at home,
and I’m pretty sure all of my guests like it too.
- You just let him ignore your recipe?
- Yeah, we tried not to for years but, uh, whatever.
- ALL DONE.
- Already? But Jerry said it takes time to evaluate if something’s good!
- [Russell Wilson:] At the end of the day, the real MVP is
someone who enjoys time with their team.
But also, please, please vote for me for MVP.
Stay tuned for our spin-off, “LET DALVIN COOK.”
- BRO, JUST GIVE ME THE EGG.
- [Together:] TEAMY WANTS YOU TO SUBSCRIBE,
But Teamy also wants…
a hug.
Just because we be Team Monster
doesn't mean we be monster monster.
AHHHH MUST EAT TO SURVIVE!